attention all potterheads potted potter
the harry potter parody combines all
seven books in a 70-minute show and it's
entertaining for anyone and everyone
even muggles so here to talk about some
of their recent exciting celebrations we
have the creators and the og stars of
potted potter dan clarkson and jeff
turner hi guys hi thank you for being
here yeah you're the original
so i have seen the show out here in
vegas and it is so entertaining i don't
even know how you guys begin to combine
all seven books into 70 minutes so let's
talk a little bit about how the idea
came about and i have to know how long
it took you to actually put it all
together it was 15 years ago when you
were probably still at school if not
even born
we came up with it was for the launch of
the sixth book and they were doing these
big midnight launches in london and so
we did it on the um sort of streets of
london to entertain the cue crew
crew just kidding entertain the queue
and then we took the show to edinburgh
where we did it sort of in the edinburgh
festival to 50 people i think at most
and now here we are where we've just
celebrated our 500th sort of performance
in vegas and we're doing vegas we're
live and we're not on zoom anymore and
this is great
it's real and we have some photos from
the celebration i heard it was a lot of
fun and did you ever think that it would
be at this point i mean it just really
turned into a phenomenon across the
world and here in vegas yeah it's
completely crazy every step we went to
london's west end then we went off
broadway we've toured the us and now
we're in vegas and we've got through the
pandemic and we're back in vegas as well
no at every step we thought that was it
that's as far as it could possibly go
who knows what's next we have a lot of
sort of pinch ourselves are we dreaming
because we are just two mates messing
around waiting for immigration to kick
us out but they haven't yet
okay well so far so good you've made it
this far absolutely okay so i have seen
all of the movies but i haven't read all
of the books but i still enjoyed the
show so even if you're not let's say a
huge harry potter fan i mean if you're
not you're crazy but if you're not you
still enjoy the show right and now you
don't have to read the books because you
saw the show
so we're saving everyone time
thank you the world
thank you guys and i have to ask like
how many times have you read the books
and seen the movies and like to do the
research for this it's very extensive
i've now read book seven eleven times
because i start the show reading it on
stage and so i've got ten minutes each
so i read it in little tiny sections
we've been doing the show for a while
now so yeah i could i could i could
quote most of that there's worse things
you can do for a living like my job is i
have to sit down with popcorn and watch
the harry potter films that's not a bad
thing life's not too bad
really difficult
oh you're a brain surgeon i watch harry
potter
life's pretty good for you guys and when
anyone thinks of harry potter they think
of quidditch you guys like put a fun
spin on it right what can people expect
when they come to the show
it's new improved coverage friendly
quidditch so now you're on brooms you're
flying around there's quaffles there's
bludgers there's dementors flying around
we've only actually ever lost two
children and they were in texas and no
one cares
not too bad of a traffic
and you guys have passed the throne over
to two other stars of the show you guys
aren't the stars in the show anymore
here in vegas but if people want to come
out and see the show where can they find
it uh we're at bali's casino every day
and uh yeah nick and james are doing the
show for us and they are fantastic
they're young they're handsome they've
got energy they're like we once were
it's amazing they've got hair and you
trust them with your projects
yeah and they're on every night they're
on tonight they've got stamina energy
come and see them and yet it's a lot of
fun thank you guys so much the show is a
blast i absolutely love it i tell
everyone to go see it all the
information is on your screen go see
potted potter at valleys you can get
tickets at potted potter